Now in terms of paper currency money how
should zaka be calculated?
>> As far as paper currency is concerned it
is interchangeable with gold and silver.
We should try and find out the value of
your paper currency and that keeps on
changing. We can either evaluate what is
the amount of currency that will reach
the nisab level either with the nisab of
the gold that is 85 g of gold or the
nisab of the silver that is 595 g of
silver. So we should try and find out
what would be the cost of 85 g of gold
in your country in your currency or 595
g of silver in your country in your
currency. Now the difference of opinion
that what should we take as nab? Should
we take the nisab of the gold or the
silver? Some of the faukah say that take
the lower limit so that a person gives
zakat even though the nisab is low. Some
of the faukas say that take the nisab
which is higher so that that gives
advantage to the poor person and need
not pay till it reaches the high level
of the nisab. While other folks say that
since silver was used as a way of
trading in the olden days, so you should
take the nisab of the silver and try and
find out what is your currency as far as
595 g of silver is concerned. But this
option is left. But if you really want
to be more sure then you can take the
lower level of nisab and normally silver
the rate of silver nowadays 595 g of
silver is much less than 85 g of